they're trying to fix inflation but
they're doing nothing to fix the
inequality which is the fundamental
problem and i think this is a little bit
the problem with the way economists
think they see the inflation but
economists have a massive blind spot for
inequality which nothing could be
illustrating it more than the way
nobody's speaking about it right now
and they're dealing with the inflation
but they're not dealing with inequality
so inflation will come down i'm very
confident inflation will
renormalize it might take a year or so
inflation will come down but inequality
will not come down and what that means
is inequality will be left permanently
higher
which will mean that ordinary people's
standard of living will be left
permanently lower and rich people's
standard living will be left permanently
higher so inflation will come down but
these changes in relative price levels
mainly that energy prices and food
prices and things like rent have become
permanent and also house prices have
become permanently significantly higher
relative to wages they will remain
so